[Music]
on this Tuesday night how prepared is
Canada for an epidemic of kovat 19 the
strain it could put on hospitals is
thank you mom that explodes but it keeps
exploding as a doctor in Italy sounds
the alarm about the dire situation there
a country under lockdown plus drastic
new measures are taken in a New York
suburb this is literally a matter of
life and death and more public events
get canceled touchy subject oh how to
keep your distance when you greet now
that handshakes hugs and kisses are on
hold and when reliability is on the line
when Via Rail admits is a serious
embarrassment
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with the impact the
corona virus is having around the world
and here in Canada there are multiple
developments tonight the number of
deaths in Italy shot up today and
doctors there have some dire warnings
and tonight dozens of Canadians who were
on board the Grand Princess cruise ship
are back in Canada settling into a
quarantine facility in Ontario 228
Canadians were on a government chartered
plane to CFB Trenton they were tested
for signs of the virus before boarding
and they'll spend the next 14 days in
isolation not on that flight several
Canadian crew members from the Grand
Princess who tested positive for kovat
19 the government didn't specify how
many are sick but we know at least 19
crew members and two passengers did test
positive before that ship docked in
California yesterday there are now 93
known cases of kovat 19 in Canada four
are in Quebec there are seven new cases
in Alberta bringing the provinces total
to 14 Ontario has 36 cases there are
seven new ones in BC for a total of 39
and two of the new cases there are
health care workers from the nursing
home in North Vancouver where a man in
his 80s died of Coe bid 19 the risk in
this country does remain low though
public health officials say to slow the
spread now is the time to practice
social distancing from other people and
to stay home if you're sick and late
today that's what the Federal Minister
of Natural Resources Seamus O'Regan
tweeted he is doing he says I've had a
persistent head cold for a few days so
as a precaution I saw a doctor they
recommended a test for Kovan 19:00 I'm
not aware of contacting anyone infected
but was told to remain in self isolation
until we get the results feel fine but
I'll work from home and tonight a
British politician announced she's
tested positive the minister in charge
of patient safety Nadine Dory's is now
self isolating officials are identifying
anyone who came in contact with her
including other MPs she recently met
hundreds of people and attended a
reception with the British prime
minister what's happening in Italy is a
warning to the rest of the world not to
be complacent
the death toll in Italy jumped by 168 in
just 24 hours
two
hundred and thirty one more than ten
thousand people have now tested positive
in Italy the entire country sixty
million people have been told to stay
home and one doctor is exposing the
chilling reality dr. Daniel machinee
says it's like a tsunami that has swept
us all he works at a hospital in Bergamo
northern Italy in a translated Facebook
post he says I understand the need not
to create panic but when the message of
the dangerousness of what's happening
does not reach people I shudder cases he
says are multiplying we arrive at a rate
of 15 to 20 admissions per day all for
the same reason the results of the swabs
now come one after the other positive
positive positive suddenly the ER is
collapsing every ventilator he says
becomes like gold today Air Canada
cancelled all flights to Italy and the
corona virus is now present all across
the European Union crystal commencing on
how the worst-hit country outside China
is coping Italians are seeing firsthand
the consequences of the new coronavirus
and it's overwhelming when it came out
in Wuhan we're all watching you need
users that looks terrible and then
started to come home to us Margaux
Leggett belani is Canadian but has been
living in Italy for 15 years she has
friends who were doctors and the
explosion of co feed 19 cases has
changed her view I think it will become
a very big problem if it's spread that
quickly in Italy it can spread quickly
anywhere it's not just where we are
about a week ago the government shut
down all schools universities plus
theaters and museums it wasn't enough on
Monday evening the nationwide ban was
announced some travel is allowed but
only for specific reasons and paperwork
is required people are also being told
to stay at least a meter away from each
other and public events such as funerals
and weddings are canceled
now grocery stores are open but not on
weekends when crowds would be larger
European leaders met today by
teleconference based on Monday's confirm
cases with 463 deaths and 9172
infections
Italy's fatality rate is at five percent
nationwide that's higher than a three to
four percent fatality rate from köppen
19 being reported in other countries
everything is very quiet except for it
sounds really terrible to say but just
your own glimpses going by this is very
almost creepy feeling the man considered
patient 1 in Italy is 38 years old he's
said to have recovered it's a bit of
hope for frontline staff fighting the
epidemic crystal commencing Global News
London
so how ready is Canada what would an
avalanche of severe respiratory illness
cases mean for our healthcare system and
our hospital emergency rooms many of
which are already over capacity
that's what Heather Urich's West is
looking at tonight inundated with calls
Monday health linked Alberta's
telehealth hotline was unable to keep up
many who called the line heard this
recording officials say more staff is
being trained to deal with the growing
demand NBC public health physicians have
been brought out of retirement to help
with testing and containment measures
Canada's health system showing signs of
pressure
even though compared to other countries
Canadian cases of kovat 19 relatively
low we had to completely reorganize the
hospital networks in Lombardy in
northern Italy the healthcare system is
under siege intensive care units have
been struggling to care for more than
600 who are now critically ill because
of kovat 19 it's not this disease itself
it's the amount the incredible
overwhelming amount of patients you have
to take care of in a limited amount of
time it's like a bomb that explodes but
keeps exploding day by day the number
seen in Lombardy are staggering 12
percent of positive cases are ending up
in the ICU staff struggle to find beds
it's more likely that ventilator
shortages will come in before ICU bed
shortages Patrick Saunders Hastings
co-authored an audit of Canada's
pandemic preparedness level three years
ago
he says despite lessons learned from
SARS and h1n1 Canada's health system may
not be ready for something as contagious
as Kovac 19 from a surge capacity
planning point of view we often
recommend the hospitals work at about
85% capacity and I don't think it will
surprise people to hear that most work
well above that in the range of sort of
a hundred to a hundred and twenty
percent the federal government says it
will help all provincial and territorial
health systems deal with additional
pressures in the coming months but for
now the focus remains on ensuring this
virus doesn't spread in Italy dr. Bruce
le agrees taking precautions now to
contain Koba 19 is key the only way to
survive this the only way to avoid the
thousands of death is to stop the spread
of the disease
Heather York's best global news Calgary
the federal government is under pressure
to be ready to respond to health care
needs and with economic measures our
chief political correspondent David akin
has been tracking one meeting of cabinet
ministers after another on Parliament
Hill today David what preparations are
being made well there's gonna be lots
now Prime Minister Justin Trudeau had a
three-hour meeting with his full cabinet
today he spent another hour with that
cabinet sub-committee on Kovan 19 and he
emerged at the end of all of that to say
there is a broad agreement that the
Canadian economy is about to slow indeed
economists now expect the GDP to shrink
by 3 percent or more that's a lot
between April and June and so his
government will soon be announcing some
steps to push in that blow and recognize
that there are going to be significant
economic impacts for Canadians for
workers for businesses and that's why
we're going to be talking very soon
about measures that Canada is going to
put forward to support people on the
economic side now how soon as sue we do
expect some measures to be announced
tomorrow and then we may hear some more
measures at the conclusion of the first
ministers meeting that Trudeau is going
to convene later in the week we have
premiers and territorial leaders coming
to town on Thursday
David the Premier's are expected to ask
Ottawa for economic help but they're
also going to have a list of things they
need for their health care systems what
do we know about that that's right we
know that Ottawa is under pressure to
made sure that provinces have enough
equipment for frontline health care
workers now doctors are sounding the
alarm over the shortage of ventilators
we'll need in the event of widespread
infection yet it was just yesterday that
this government wrote to premiers to
find out what their needs are that is a
failure of emergency preparedness Davies
is referring to a letter Global News
obtained over the weekend that was
signed by the Prime Minister addressed
to all the premiers and asks them to
come to this week's first ministers
meeting with a list of supplies the
provinces need now the idea behind all
that is it is the federal government
that is in the best place to make a bulk
purchase of those supplies and then
distribute them where they're needed
Donna okay David akin and Ottawa thanks
in the US the governor of Washington
state is putting new measures in place
after a kovat 19 outbreak at a nursing
home north of Seattle all staff and
volunteers working at nursing homes and
assisted living facilities across
Washington State will now be screened
for symptoms at the start of each shift
visitations will be limited and visitors
will also be screened as they enter
other states are also limiting visitors
to nursing homes at least 19 residents
at the life care center in Kirkland
Washington state have now died 55 other
residents have tested positive and 21 of
them are still at the facility across
Washington State there are at least 267
confirmed cases of Kovan 19 and 23
deaths one of the other outbreaks in the
u.s. is just outside New York City in
Westchester County a containment zone is
in place now New York City's mayor says
private labs that began running
coronavirus tests on Friday are
reporting so many new cases public
officials are having trouble keeping up
there are more than 950 known cases in
the US now at least 28 deaths today
President Trump assured Americans the
virus will go away and everyone should
remain calm Abigail Beeman reports
st. Patrick's Day parades in Seattle San
Francisco and Boston canceled really
thinking about protection of people the
list of events keeps growing Santa Clara
California issued a countywide ban on
large gatherings putting San Jose Sharks
games in jeopardy
New Jersey saw its first death and New
York announced a one-mile containment
zone in New Rochelle where there has
been a cluster of more than 100 cases
we're also going to use the National
Guard in the containment area to deliver
food to homes to help with the cleaning
of public spaces Harvard is the latest
university to cancel in-person classes
asking students to move out of dorms
meanwhile on the Grand Princess cruise
ship while the healthy Canadians left
disembarking all 3,500 people will take
longer dual Canadian American citizens
Eva and Ron Weiss burger have launched a
million dollar lawsuit against the
ship's parent company alleging it didn't
adequately screen or warn passengers
about the threat but you can't just
Corona a virus and has a severe heart
condition like I do it could be fatal
the cruise industry along with Airlines
have been hit hard President Donald
Trump also hinted at economic help in
the form of payroll tax cuts and relief
for hourly wage earners and help for
people to get tested the government has
been criticized for its slow rollout
these CEOs have also agreed to no
surprise billing we want people to get
it tested meanwhile Trump himself has
yet to do it well I don't think it's a
big deal I would do it I don't feel that
any reason I feel extremely good I feel
very good there are at least half a
dozen US lawmakers who have chosen to
self quarantine after they came into
contact with someone who tested positive
for the new corona virus and two of them
came into contact with the president
including one who flew with him on Air
Force One
Abigail Beeman Global News Washington
China's president went to the epicenter
of the outbreak there for the first time
since it began more than two months ago
state media reported Xi Jingping flew in
to inspect coronavirus control efforts
his visit coincides with the shutdown of
the last emergency hospital set up in
Wuhan to manage a surge in coal
mid-nineteen cases China announced it
had just 19 new cases on Monday down
from 40 the day before we know you have
lots of questions about this virus and
we want to try to answer them you can
send an email to your questions at
Global News CA our Jeff sample will
consult experts to try to find the
answers you'll also find extensive
information on our website we have a
special page dedicated entirely to the
new corona virus that's at global news
dot CA / corona virus kovat 19 is
affecting the Democratic presidential
race coming up what the frontrunners are
doing to try to limit the spread
the frontrunner for the Democratic
nomination have called off their
campaign rallies in Cleveland Ohio
tonight because of the corona virus
the first major disruptions to the
presidential primaries this is a pivotal
time for Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders
they're trying to win over delegates in
six states in what's being called Super
Tuesday the second both said they're
heating advice to exercise caution about
holding large public gatherings both
campaigns said they will decide on
future events on a case-by-case basis in
the coming days
Vladimir Putin the Russian president has
opened the door to constitutional
changes that would allow him to stay in
power until 2036 Putin is 67 now he
served four presidential terms and a
stint as Prime Minister dominating the
Russian political landscape for 20 years
his latest term expires in 2024 if the
Constitutional Court approves the change
and it's expected it will Putin could
remain in power until he's 83 still
ahead lagging locomotives have via
passengers railing for change
[Music]
as part of a global news investigation
into rail service we're looking at just
how reliable it is trains have connected
Canada for more than a century but in
the last few decades a number of factors
have started causing costly delays
tonight Megan Robinson looks at what's
happening on and off the tracks there
was a time when the fastest way from
Toronto to Vancouver was by train with
railway stations at the heart of many
Canadian cities the timetables from 70
years ago show the cross-country trip
has become 14 hours slower if you're
lucky you're sitting there going what is
going on here one trip in January 2018
from Toronto to Vancouver was 43 hours
behind schedule
none of the westbound Canadian trains
were on time that month with an average
delay of 29 hours we haven't invested in
train travel especially for people
rather than goods
cien owns the tracks Canada's only
passenger rail service uses for the
Canadian the Toronto to Vancouver route
and says its other customers pay more
than 250 billion dollars the ship
products like oil grain and timber every
year passenger trains don't get priority
on the track and those are the money
train they leave that affects they good
to Vancouver and get off of their way a
Via Rail trains wait the delays have
cost the company millions and expenses
like overtime for their employees who
deliver bad news to passengers I'm 55 I
retired lucky me but I could have done
another 10 years but I cannot sustain
this I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry constantly
about 10 years ago the Canadian was on
time 84 percent of the time in both
directions but then things started to go
downhill just 8 percent of trains on the
route were on time in 2017 with a small
increase the following year I have to
plan to lose a day because of how much I
have to cut my schedule with all the
delays that I can encounter so
one of the last trips I took I just
expected to 12-hour delay that was just
normal in a recent report Via Rail says
the situation is a serious embarrassment
and the performance of the Canadians
should serve as the canary in a coal
mine for what will happen sooner or
later
on its busiest routes in Ontario and
Quebec if no action is taken
but Via Rail isn't just worried about
delays it also warned without
improvements it can no longer offer
viable passenger rail services which
could help reduce traffic and pollution
from cars and planes if we want train to
be a real viable alternative for people
to get around we have to make sure that
there's lots of ways to live near the
Train there's lots of places to go that
are connected to the Train the federal
government says it's reviewing the
situation cien spent billions of dollars
in recent years to reduce congestion on
tracks but passenger delays persist I
can understand a breakdown I can
understand irregularities but for us to
be held up on the tracks like that given
zero priority you felt like we were
being shuffled around like cattle some
train advocates have been calling for a
new law that would give Via Rail more
power and make it easier to punish
companies causing delays but the federal
government tells us they're not
considering it
Megan Robinson Global News Toronto
tomorrow we look at the federal
government's track record on investing
in rail and a new commitment on better
connecting Canada's two biggest cities
next how the world is fighting off the
virus by shaking off handshakes
you
well you know by now the handshake is on
hold as Co vid 19 continues to spread so
our hugs and kisses and nose rubs keep
your distance
is the new mantra tonight Michael look
at aura looks at the creative ways
people are finding to say hello and
goodbye stop with kovat 19 spreading
across the netherlands dutch Prime
Minister Mark Rutte a announces a
countrywide ban on shaking hands and
then does this country's top doctor
points out the mistake so route a asks
for a do-over while actually getting
closer than a handshake
the royal family known for being slow to
abandon tradition is instead adjusting
Prince Charles greeting with a bow and
pressed hands instead of pressing the
flesh while Prince Harry opted for the
forearm bump last week British Prime
Minister Boris Johnson refused to shake
the handshake I'm shaking hands conceal
a visitor I was at a hospital the other
night to where I think there were a few
there were actually a few coronavirus
patients and I shook hands with
everybody but he's said to be
reconsidering the practice after all the
handshake is such a part of politics the
Deputy Prime Minister Christopher
Freeland mixed it up at the Ontario
Liberal Convention last weekend
Ottawa's mayor is still shaking hands as
he toured the city's Chinatown to
counter some discrimination being felt
in that community and Jim Watson admits
these are difficult times we're in this
sort of awkward position sometimes
people have to give you a hand and then
they'll give you a fist bump and someone
was giving me an elbow so I keep Purell
in my car I keep Purell at my desk and I
use it as often as possible
and so far so good good advice according
to health officials I think if you are
completely well then there's not really
much risk of shaking someone's hand that
is also well but sometimes it's hard to
know if the other person is healthy or
not which has given birth to the toe tap
or foot shake done here by Russia's
Energy Minister and OPEX
secretary-general two members of the
Philadelphia 76ers started their own
special shake virtual hand sanitizing a
good option but instead they should
probably be doing the real thing mike
lacouture global news Ottawa that is
global national for this Tuesday I'm
Donna Friesen tonight share Canada is
Saskatoon we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to us and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you